[Music]
so
foreign
[Music]
so
when life throws a curveball at you it's
how you react that matters canceling the
conference was never an option
not for us and not for you thank you so
much for attending
if you have any questions we are
available on slack we also have a webex
meeting where you can meet us in person
at the infobooth
channel to all of our speakers waiting
to present to you
from their homes thank you so much for
speaking to all our fantastic partners
thanks for sticking with us through this
you rock these are awesome companies
special thanks to our exhibitors you'll
find them at our virtual expo make sure
you visit them
there are some amazing prizes to be won
we'll do live prize draws during
every lunch break thanks to the agenda
committee
for putting together a fantastic agenda
you did a great job
so wherever you are in the world we hope
you enjoy the show
anything you want to add to this student
good morning good morning good morning
welcome everybody
to nbc london 2021
big hello let's get away from all the
folks who are watching live on webex
uh let's get a big shout out in the chat
from all the folks who are watching live
on youtube
hello everybody it's great to see you
all um
and for me i actually get to welcome all
of you to a place i actually am
it's been a very strange year for
conferences this time last year
we were here in the the city of
westminster which is the city
inside the city of london and uh ndc
london 2020 was in full swing
we had about a thousand people we had
five days of workshops and content and
tracks and parties and pub conf and all
that kind of stuff um
now the world has changed a little bit
since
we last did that uh we are still doing
ndc of course we are canceling it like
uh
like allen said in the video cancelling
it was never an option
and at nbc london last year i did a
presentation in the last slot on friday
about a thing called the art of code
now this was kind of a bit of fun for me
it's a talk that i put together
about things i wanted to talk about uh
you know it was a
sort of meandering riff through art and
fractal geometry and esoteric languages
and music and stuff
and uh i know how bored you have all
been
since all the lockdowns and the pandemic
restrictions and everything started
do you know how i know how bored people
have been
because 1.8 million people have watched
that art of code video
since it was put up in february last
year i say 1.8 million people
about half of that is me going and
refreshing it to see if the numbers have
gone up yet because uh
lockdown is difficult for extroverts and
our egos need a little buzz wherever we
can get it
but a lot of people have watched it and
a lot of people seem to have liked it
and uh you know when when we started
thinking about putting ndc london 2021
together
the crew said to me you know do you
fancy doing a keynote that's something
kind of like the art of code and
uh you know somebody said to me well
have you got anything else to talk about
i'm like
what you think i i took a one-hour talk
and i literally said everything there is
to say about the interplay between
art and music and computers and
programming and creativity
we have only scratched the surface
because there are so many more
ideas to explore and things to talk
about and what i want to share with all
of you this morning
to welcome you all and kick off ndc
london 2021.
the title of this talk is computational
creativity
and i was bouncing around a whole bunch
of ideas and what i wanted to do was
take a look at some of those
those same ideas about this sort of the
synergy that exists when human beings
and technology
combine to create something interesting
uh hulking says can't see slides yes
thank you hawking there we go
um
so computational creativity i just kind
of came up with this phrase while i was
i was playing around
with some ideas and things um a little
while ago i was reading this book
uh this is sid meier's memoir you may
know sid meier he's the
game designer who built a civilization
or you know civ one two three four five
a
game where the integer overflow means
gandhi turns into a nuclear terrorist
you ever played that one
um and railroad tycoon and a whole bunch
of different games
and i was just kind of reading this book
and i stumbled across this this little
lovely phrase one this phrase
computational creativity it cropped up
and i was like hey
i thought of that thought of that that's
kind of nice um he's using it in
reference to a project that goes way
back to the 90s
about building computer games that can
generate original murder mysteries
so you can play a detective and you have
to solve crimes and every time you play
it it's a different mystery with
different clues
which i think is a lovely idea and
possibly a subject for another talk
um but there's also a phrase just before
that in the book
where he says it was only a little bit
impossible
which is not the same as completely
impossible and i was thinking about that
phrase because i was thinking you know
if i'd said to the rest of the crew
this time last year hey you know next
year we're going to do ndc london over
the internet and and nobody's going to
be in the room
they'd all have said no that's
impossible but it's only a little bit
impossible it's not completely
impossible
and so here we are and here all of you
are streaming
watching live from uh all over the world
uh marco says in youtube comment pirates
yeah said maya
did the pirates game as well and all his
games end with an exclamation mark which
i really liked
um now as you probably all know by now
when we run these kinds of online events
we're relying on a huge amount of
technology to keep everything working
uh there's a rule that says the success
of a performance is directly
proportional to
the number of meters of cable that are
involved um well we've probably got
something like
200 maybe 300 000 kilometers of cable
involved in me being able to talk to all
you this morning so if anything goes
wrong
don't worry about it just relax you know
check your twitter and everything
we'll reboot the thing we'll be back up
with you as soon as we can
but let's get started let's kick off ndc
london 2021
and we are going to start at the
beginning we are gonna go back in time
about 40 000 years these are some cave
paintings
that were discovered in indonesia in
and these cave paintings archaeologists
believe
this is the oldest art ever the oldest
evidence they've ever found of human
beings
creating art and there's two things
about this that i think are wonderful
you know
one we were making art you know as soon
as human beings worked out hey we can
use this stuff to make marks on the wall
of the cave they're like what should we
draw
and the other thing the archaeologists
who've studied this they've discovered
it shows a hunt there's this big animal
and there's a bunch of little human
figures you can just kind of barely make
out that are hunting it
but one of the human figures has a
bird's head and another one of the human
figures
has a tail and so it's fiction it's
creative as soon as people worked out
they could make marks on a cave wall
to show this hunting scene they're like
let's make something up what can we do
what can we put here
this idea of using technology to explore
things that don't really exist and
you know fiction fantasy imagination i
think that's a wonderful idea
something that i want to dig into now
those cave paintings started
this long tradition of visual art you
know we had a
michelangelo we had da vinci we had a
frida kahlo and hokusai and
all of these different schools and
styles sculptures graffito
oils paintings watercolors and in around
a group of artists based in france
founded a movement
that they called realism the realists
were fed up of you know romanticized
pictures of
john the baptist and king louis they
wanted to paint
real life as accurately as they possibly
could
they painted real scenes and they strove
for
it wasn't called photographic realism
because the phrase didn't exist yet but
they wanted paintings
that looked like reality ordinary people
just going and doing ordinary things
but even as the realism movement was
getting started
its days were already numbered because
the second half of the 19th century
we saw a technological innovation that
was going to change the world
we saw the advent of photography now as
soon as
cameras were invented film cameras and
then motion cameras and eventually
digital cameras
realism was effectively obsolete you
know if something really happened you
could just point a camera at it
and capture it why would you strive for
days meticulously recreating reality
with brush strokes
when you could just point and shoot now
you know the early film cameras you had
to sit very still for a very long time
it was a
very expensive proposition but one of
the things we've seen with every form of
technology is as soon as we figured out
how to do it
it starts getting easier and cheaper and
easier and cheaper and we went from
you know old black and white films to
compact films to 35 mil
to digital to smartphones and now it
seems like you know
almost everything that ever happens in
the world
somebody took a picture of it or took a
video of it because
photography is absolutely ubiquitous so
next time
that and whenever this may be next time
you're out with a group of friends and
you're having some drinks and someone
goes hey
let's get a selfie spare a thought for
the realists
a group of humans and a whole avenue of
human endeavor that was just sort of
rendered obsolete by technology this
photograph by the way i would like to
credit it but i don't know who it's from
um it was posted anonymously to reddit
as a response to the question what is
the drunkest photograph you have ever
seen
um and you know i think it's beautiful
i'd almost like to get a realist painter
to recreate this just to close that loop
but photography was just one example
of you know technology having this
profound impact on
the way people interact with the world
around them from 1760 until the middle
of the 19th century
the world experienced an industrial
revolution
the industrial revolution textiles
agriculture mining manufacturing
hundreds of you know
human beings and the industries in which
they worked were dramatically changed by
machinery
and automation and technology and you
know the impacts of those
changes are still visible today
some of you may have come across this
word luddite
which is a you know not terribly
complementary term that's applied to
people
who just don't want to get with the
program when it comes to technology
right
um yeah people i i've had eyes a luddite
he doesn't want a computer on his desk
oh you know a bunch of luddites they
don't want to join an online conference
they don't want to get a smartphone this
kind of thing
um the term luddite is actually named
after a person who's portrayed here as a
man called ned ludd
ludd was a weaver and he destroyed a
pair of looms he took a hammer and he
smashed up a pair of textile weaving
frames
because he was worried he was angry that
these machines were coming along that
were going to replace
the craft of weaving human beings making
textiles um
maybe it's true maybe it's a folk story
but nedlar's name has gone down in
history as sort of synonymous with this
fear and destruction of technology um
and you know you think about it
weaving used to be something that
artisans did and if you had woven cloth
that was a status symbol
and suddenly overnight they're like now
we've got machines that can just kind of
churn out this stuff
and so you know we have this word
luddite in ned lud's honor centuries
later
but for every innovation that technology
delivers there are always going to be
the people who embrace that change
people who look at it
and they go you know this is this is
amazing we can work with this we can do
things with this
and there are the people who are going
to resist that change and those
changes they raise all kinds of
questions about uh
innovation and creativity liability and
that's
what i want to talk to all of you about
today
we're gonna fast forward to the 1950s in
the 1950s the word computer
was a job title applied to human beings
any companies organizations that needed
to do arithmetic the military
aviation engineering they employed
computers halls full of them human
beings who'd sit there all day with
pencils
and paper and slide rules and they would
perform calculations
now if any of you read the book or seen
the movie hidden figures
book the movie came out in 2016. it
tells the story of a group of
computers people who were working at
nasa during the 1950s doing calculations
for
the united states space program uh
the people who did the calculations that
put alan shepard in orbit and landed
apollo on the moon
and if you've seen the movie you
probably remember this scene right
ibm 7090 data processing system
it has the capability of solving over
24 000 multiplications
per second holy moses that's lightning
fast they'll never get that to work
no it'll run eventually and when it does
we have to know how to program it
unless you'd rather be out of a job
so the um actress there octavia spencer
is playing
a real person called dorothy vaughn and
dorothy worked at nasa until 1971. she
was one of the first people to work on
programming one of the first ibm
mainframe systems in an early version of
fortran
by the time dorothy von left nasa human
beings had
walked on the moon we'd invented the
hewlett-packard pocket scientific
calculator
the intel 4004 microprocessor which was
the kind of
the earliest version of the instruction
set that we still
use today the 4004 processor had been
released xerox had invented the laser
printer
um the arpanet existed ip addresses were
a thing
email was a thing and the word computer
was
definitely not a job title anymore and
we had
started to struggle with this whole idea
about the the dialogue between human
beings and technology and the extent to
which it's okay to rely on them
now i'm sure some of you are of the
generation
that had the arguments with your
teachers when you were in school
about whether you were allowed to use a
calculator
now i had the you know the teachers
would be like you have to learn your
times tables and i'd be like
why i have a calculator and i'd say well
when you grow up you won't always have a
calculator in your pocket
uh hands up anyone who has a calculator
app on their phone and their phone is in
their pocket right now
i'm sorry mrs marshall it turns out when
we grow up we all have calculators
in our pockets but you know arithmetic
is not
that big a deal arithmetic as distinct
from
you know mathematics arithmetic is
not very creative you do a summer or an
equation and you get the right answer
and it doesn't matter how you got there
you don't get bonus points for doing it
in an interesting way
um you know all that matters is how do
we get the right answer the faster the
better especially
if you are trying to beat the soviet
union to land the first mission on the
moon right
and so the whole idea of calculators
well yeah if you need to do sums in a
hurry and they need to be right of
course you use a calculator don't do it
by hand what are you doing with that
now when i was in school i was kind of a
nerdy kid
and in the early 1990s you know my my
parents my folks had a computer that i
used to use to do my homework i would
write essays and things
and i got into these ongoing arguments
with my teachers about whether i was
allowed to use a spell checker
because there was one school of thought
that said you go to school to learn to
read and write and spell if you use a
spell checker that's cheating
and there was another school of thought
that says this technology is available
and you should learn to use it because
if it means that you write better essays
kind of who cares how they got there and
we eventually
after lots of negotiation arrived at
this
very very weird compromise
where i was allowed to use a spell
checker for like history and geography
homework
because my english teacher was like
those subjects are not teaching you how
to spell
but you're not allowed to use a spell
checker for doing your english homework
because if you make spelling mistakes i
need to be able to correct them
um and you know i sort of said to her
but a spell check works just like a
dictionary and she said no no if you
look words up in a dictionary
then you'll find out what they mean and
i said to her why would i be using a
word in my essay if i don't know what it
means
um and this kind of went back and forth
in a fairly good-natured way
but the point is you know dictionary
spell checkers all this kind of stuff
they're not actually creative tools all
they're doing is taking what you've
given them and saying hey did i find
that
in this list over here and the classic
problem with spell checkers was
immortalized in this wonderful poem by a
guy called gerald zarr
i have a spelling checker it came with
my pc it plainly marks for my review
mistakes i cannot see i strike a key and
type a word
and wait for it to say whether i am
wrong or right
it shows me straight away
now when i wasn't in school arguing with
my teachers about calculators and spell
checkers
i was a teenager in the 1990s and it was
kind of fun
and the coolest thing that happened when
i was a teenager doing mrs jones english
class
was that this movie came out terminator
2 judgment day terminator had
everything it had uh on schwarzenegger
and it had time traveling killer robots
from the future
and it had a guns n roses soundtrack and
it had all those
one-liners hasta la vista baby and all
that kind of stuff
and it had some of the best visual
effects
that anyone had ever seen in a motion
picture
the uh team from industrial light and
magic who put this together they were
using
computer technology to realize things
that you know nobody had ever
seen on a cinema screen before we'd
never seen anything like this
you know we had this liquid metal robot
that could change its
shape to mimic anything that it touched
which became a kind of you know pivotal
point and it won loads of awards for the
effects it was an absolute smash hit
blockbuster movie
but terminator 2 was not the first movie
that used computers 1982
stephen lisberger directed and produced
this movie it was released by the disney
corporation
it's a film called tron it's a film
about computers
made using computers the story of a
programmer who gets sucked into the
mainframe and has to
fight his way back out against all kinds
of evil corporate programs
which is a sort of parable for
developers working in the enterprise
everywhere
and the story of how tron got made was
absolutely fascinating
um tron combined hand animation computer
animation and live action
in a way nobody had seen before take a
look at this is
[Music]
watching
tron was one of the most visually
stunning movies ever made
tron did not win any academy awards for
visual effects
because it was disqualified the uh
motion picture academy of arts and
sciences the people who give at the
oscars
they said that using computers to make a
film
was cheating it just wasn't in the
spirit of the thing now
you know at the time the hollywood
machine employed
thousands of set dressers and carpenters
and animators and makeup people and
costume people
and you can see why you know they're
like they can make a movie on a computer
what are all these people going to do
for a job
if they can do that now you know
obviously that's not quite how it went
down
um computers just became a sort of
another tool in the filmmakers
palette filmmaker's arsenal you know um
but the the tron was actually all the
animation it was funded by disney disney
paid for it disney distributed it
but all of the animation was done in
taiwan because disney's animators
refused to work on it they said we are
not
kind of you know putting nails into our
own coffin here we are not prepared to
work with you on this
now the really interesting thing about
that is tron wasn't the first movie to
use computer graphics
there were computer graphics before that
but they were always like in the film
there would be a computer on screen with
graphics on the computer screen and
hollywood kind of thought that was fine
as long as they stay in the computer and
it's obvious they're on a computer then
that's all right we're not worried about
that
but there were also at the time when
tron was made
it was cheaper to fake it this is from
john carpenter's escape from new york
snake pliskin flying his glider into
manhattan to go and rescue the president
who's been
kidnapped by gangsters and look at the
navigation display on his plane here
that looks like a green screen wireframe
computer graphic right
it's not that is a warehouse full of
cardboard boxes
they have been painted black they have
had a stripe of green paint put along
all the corners
and the second unit director on that
movie got one of those ultraviolet disco
lights
and he just walked through it with a
movie camera so you got this gliding
effect
um the person who directed that scene
was james cameron who went on to make
terminator 2 and titanic
and found his own digital effects
company digital domain
so if you wanted computer graphics on a
screen in the 1980s the easiest thing to
do was to fake it with cardboard and
string and
you know ultraviolet light to make tron
they used this thing this is a computer
called the phoonly f1 it was the only
one in the world it was a
massively overclocked pvp 10 and they
would take
six hours to render a single frame of
footage and then they'd press a button
and it would expose one frame of the
film
advance the film and then they'd press
render on the next thing they couldn't
combine human beings and computer
footage in the same shot so anyway you
see people on screen those computer
graphics were drawn by hand
and the scenes where you just see the
machines and the sets and things those
are all computer generated
the academy eventually came to their
senses they realized that yep that's
probably fine if you want to use
computers then that's all right we'll
let you do that and they gave tron a
lifetime achievement award in
recognition of how it changed the motion
picture industry
but let's think about a shot like this
one you know from from terminator 2
because by the time they made
the balance it flipped and uh computers
were making you didn't have to fake it
anymore the computer would just kind of
spit out what you you asked for it
and this raises a new question you know
you look at this
this shot here now you got the liquid
metal robot reflecting the floor and the
directors lined up the shot but that
robot wasn't there
when they filmed it that was put in
later with a computer running an
algorithm written by a programmer who
wasn't a movie director so who gets
the credit you know who created that
shot and in terminator 2 it was very
much kind of storyboarded
robot comes out of the floor looks like
this and they have pencil sketches and
they just try and achieve that
but about a decade 15 years later
we started seeing scenes like this
now in these scenes this is from peter
jackson's lord of the rings trilogy this
is 2002.
um the computer isn't just rendering the
computer isn't just the animator
all of those soldiers on that
battlefield
they are being played acted by the
computers a system called massive
uh that combines ai routines with
routing path algorithms behavior
algorithms
and so the director can say give me 20
000 orcs over there 20 000 elves over
there
big trebuchet war machine in the middle
boom action let them fight
so there's no human acting going on
there's no human costuming going on
and the director just kind of goes right
bring the camera around here almost like
they're shooting reportage footage on a
real battlefield you know um there is a
lovely story about this
uh the when they first put these things
on the screen
in the the return of the king movie uh
some of the little computer generated
extras
saw the mummer like war elephants and
they turn around and they ran off the
battlefield
and uh there was an interview with one
of the weta was the company one of the
artists said well
actually all that was happening was they
realized that over there was crowded and
they were looking for empty space
because we had a kind of frequency
distribution algorithm but the story of
these little digital soldiers getting
terrified and running away was too good
to pass up so we let that one go around
in the press for a couple of years
um but so far so good you know it's
fantasy it's obviously not real you know
we're not we know that this was not
filmed
on location in middle earth and that no
war elephants were harmed during the
making of this movie
um but then this guy comes along
believe i owe you an apology director
clinic
your work exceeds all expectations
now that character is grand moff tarkin
who first appeared on our cinema screens
in 1977
in the first star wars movie played by
the british actor
peter cushing peter cushing is dead
peter cushing died i think in 2003
and so when the makers of the star wars
rogue one movie wanted to bring this
character back you know they had this do
we recast it
do we like replace it with a different
character what do we do
and it raised all sorts of interesting
questions there was a review of one of
the star wars movies that said we live
in an age where computers mean you can
have
dead actors playing living characters
and living actors playing dead
characters
i just want to show you a tiny little
snippet from the abc nightline program
from the team who did that uh the peter
cushing grand moff talking effect
because it's really insightful seeing
how they put it together underneath
digital tarkin
is a real actor guy henry who carefully
studied cushing on the set
lost in the attack it's henry's voice
and performance that the ilm artist used
as a guide the original plans for this
station are kept there
charming to the last this is the
earliest test
as the first time we ever saw guy's
motion
transferred onto guy's model and then
put onto tarkin's
first like an early likeness the problem
is cushing's performance and henry's
performance didn't always match
that required painstaking sometimes
frame by frame adjustments
constantly refining the most subtle
details you can imagine
the makers of rogue one had the blessing
of cushing's estate but the effect
is drawing some criticism over the
ethics of bringing back well-known
actors
long after they're gone now
anyone who's seen the cats movie will
know that sometimes
computer computers just they give
filmmakers too much power and they do
things
that just should never have been done we
should have stopped
before we got to that point um but so
far we talked about hollywood we talked
about you know big budget
lots of uh you know professional
animators and everything
and we are entering an age now where
you don't need hollywood anymore you
know take a look at this
we're entering an era in which our
enemies can make it look like anyone is
saying anything at any point in time
even if they would never say those
things so
for instance they could have me say
things like
i don't know killmonger was right
now you see i would never say these
things
at least not in a public address but
someone else would
someone like jordan peel
this is a dangerous time
moving forward we need to be more
vigilant with what we trust from the
internet
so that's what has become known as deep
fake technology
which is almost at the point where you
can go here's a bunch of photographs of
a famous person
or somebody i know here is me talking to
camera
um make it look like they were doing the
talking and it will spit out video
footage that is a
frighteningly plausible in a lot of
scenarios which raises questions exactly
as the you know it says in in the piece
here
um who do you trust how do you know who
to trust and what happens if that trust
relationship
is abused now historically we have had a
rigorous framework of laws
around publishing and people being
responsible for what they decide to say
if
a newspaper printed a story on their
front page that i was having a romantic
liaison
with ja ja binks i can sue them
if that wasn't true and we'll assume
that it's not true i could sue them
because they have made a decision there
was a conscious
agency involved in doing that somebody
said we are going to print the story
either we believe it's true in which
case they are negligent or they know
it's not true and they print it anyway
in which case they are malicious
in either case i can sue that newspaper
for damages
damage to my reputation um now obviously
with newspapers
the only things that make it onto the
printed page are the things that the
journalists were paid to put there
the editors look at it the copywriters
look at it the whole thing has people
involved at every step of it
as the internet started to take off and
pick up steam we realized that we were
gonna have a problem and in the 1990s
there was a window where it looked for a
while like internet providers isps
might be liable for anything that was
transmitted over their network you know
imagine that
i'm uh i'm on a network isp called
plusnet right here at home right now so
if i go on a website and i see something
i don't like
i can sue plusnet i say yeah your
network showed me something that isn't
true
i'm suing you for it you know um this
was obviously gonna threaten
all sorts of possible and potential uh
revenue and content and business models
for the internet
and so the uh freedom from these kinds
of restrictions
very quickly became codified in law in
the united states
where it kind of has the most impact
single section 230 of the communications
decency act
no provider or user of an interactive
computer service
shall be treated as the publisher or
speaker of
any information provided by another
information content provider
what that means is that if i say
something about you on facebook
that's my problem that's not facebook's
problem if you want to sue you've got to
assume me
can't sue facebook you can't see your
internet provider you can't sue my
internet provider you can't sue the
people who provided the
undersea cable which allowed your
provider to talk to my provider
um i am the publisher or speaker and
nobody else will be treated
as the publisher or speaker and you know
i think this is a good thing the
electronic freedom foundation thinks
this is a good thing it is one of the
most rigorous protections
of online free speech it's also you know
imagine trying to run a website like
github or stack overflow
if you could be legally liable for
anything that anybody
said you know somebody puts a defamatory
comment about bill gates in a github
repository somewhere
and someone decides they're going to sue
github because they don't like it you
know it would make a lot of the social
media and collaboration platforms we
rely on effectively unworkable
um but it was all based on the idea that
the platforms were neutral
within the last probably five ten years
we've seen
a shift away from neutrality on those
platforms but it's not because the
content on them
is being curated by human beings if you
go on to twitter and you go and click
the options in the top
um you get this thing home shows you top
tweets for what are top tweets
now top tweets means that something
somewhere
in twitter's giant infrastructure is
looking at all of there's no way you can
keep up with twitter there is too much
of it
and so this algorithm the top tweets
algorithm
it chooses things to show me that it
thinks i am gonna engage with
because the drive here is engagement
people clicks
eyeballs attention span things that
twitter can sell to advertisers if you
are not paying for a service
you are the product and they are selling
you to somebody else that is the mantra
of how social media revenue models work
so
if the the twitter algorithm decides
that i'm interested in stories saying
uh you know giving a particular
editorial perspective on something like
the u.s elections or the coronavirus
pandemic
um you know is anybody liable is there
anybody
involved in that who i can go and say
you showed all these people something
that wasn't true and as a result we now
have these problems to deal with you
know
because it's not a human being making
the recommendations much as we'd like to
think it is there is no editor-in-chief
working at youtube or facebook or
twitter or any of these platforms you
know it's just
recommendation algorithms and the thing
you've got to remember about the
recommendation algorithms
is they are optimizing for the perfect
youtube viewer is somebody who wanders
in one afternoon and goes ah look at
this youtube thing everyone's talking
about
um and they never go outside again
because the recommendation algorithm is
doing its job so well
that at the end of every video there is
another video
you know youtube end of everything it
says what do you want to watch next
and it's probably me doing art of code
at ndc london but it's
never going to be hey that's enough
youtube for today
go outside you know phone your mother
get some fresh air maybe drink a glass
of water
that is never the recommendation hey you
know read a book
talk to somebody go and have a chat with
your neighbor it's always here's another
video
and the videos that you watch to the end
they feed into the algorithm and the
videos that you skip halfway through the
like all right it doesn't like that
no more of that kind of stuff now this
is just you know it's not
a good or an evil algorithm it's just an
algorithm that has been optimized
to encourage a particular pattern of
behavior and i think some
recommendation algorithms are fantastic
i quite often i listen to spotify a lot
and spotify has this is your daily mix
and i'll just be like you know
spotify just play music and it'll just
start picking tracks and i'll be like oh
i love this song i've not heard it in
years and i'll be you know dancing
around the kitchen
singing and playing air guitar and stuff
um and it's youtube's recommendation
algorithm randomly one day popped up and
said you should watch this
it's a guy in switzerland who restores
rusty old machine tools that he found
um and it's mesmerizing and it's it's
wonderful
chill out it's called my mechanics and
it's just no dialogue no music it's just
a guy with a bunch of tools fixing up
all these
battered old machines and appliances and
stuff and it's it's wonderful
um but you know all this stuff this idea
about running algorithms and everything
it raises questions you know is it the
algorithm is it the reliability of the
underlying platform
is it the people who spec the algorithm
the people who built it
how does all of that work we're going to
take a step back we're going to look at
the whole thing now from a slightly
different perspective
um because i want to talk about a
company who had a a memorable experience
when it comes to using algorithms to
make recommendations
it was a company called night capital
in 2012 knight capital was the single
largest equities trader on the new york
stock exchange
they accounted for something like 70 17
one seven percent of all the trades on
the new york stock exchange and the same
on the nasdaq the high-tech uh share
trading index
now in 2012 the new york stock exchange
introduced some new rules they said
we're changing the regulations
to make it a little bit easier for
people to use automated systems to
help you know automate the process of
buying and selling stock it's going to
roll out in uh
in august 2012 so the folks at knight
capital
they upgraded their software and they
made a bunch of changes and they
got everything ready to roll out to
integrate with the new retail liquidity
program
and on august the 1st they rolled this
upgrade out
onto eight servers they had eight
servers in their trading
uh cluster except they made a mistake
they actually only rolled it out onto
seven
now this is where it gets uh probably
relatable for anybody who's worked on
big legacy systems
inside their algorithmic trading system
as a system called smart
there was a feature that they called
powerpeg and uh
powerpeg's job was if you said i want to
buy 10 000 shares of that
powerpeg would be like all right that
company has 280 for sale
grab them okay bring it down how many do
we need now that right that company
grabbed them how many how many and
eventually it'd be like right that's it
we've got all 10 000 shares uh powerpeg
had been
stopped they stopped using it nine years
earlier so this code had been sat
dormant in production for nearly a
decade um
they had removed the transaction limit
feature
that for some reason just wasn't there
anymore um
but it was okay because it wasn't
running because it was switched off
using
a feature flag using a configuration
flag
the people who put in the retail
liquidity index changes they reused that
feature flag so when they rolled out the
new configuration seven of the servers
started trading on the new stock
exchange rules
and one of them reactivated the old
powerpeg code
and started issuing trades um the
transaction limit feature was gone
so as soon as somebody said hey buy a
thousand shares of that
we basically had an infinite loop
spending real money doing trades on the
new york stock exchange
um the securities and equities
commission report on this
is very short and it's surprisingly
funny for a financial report
it includes this memorable phrase they
had accumulated an
unintended multi-million dollar
portfolio of securities
in approximately 45 minutes they had
bought 460 million dollars worth of
stock they didn't want
because of a loop in an algorithm that
they didn't realize with their
uh first thing that they did when it
started going wrong is they rolled the
code back on all the other seven servers
but they didn't reset the config flag so
now they had eight servers spending real
money on stuff they didn't want on the
stock exchange
um it basically wiped the company out
they lost half a billion dollars
and they had to pay a 12 million dollar
fine which has really got to sting when
you've just lost half a billion um
and you know the questions that i have
they went down in history you know it
pretty much wiped out night capital as a
trading thing this was their
their stock price over the the course of
that incident
and they've gone down in history as a
really good example of what not to do
that's useful for people like me who
write talks about uh famous incidents
from stuff
um but you know who's to blame the
engineer who you know do you
ever in your job do you roll out
upgrades onto servers um if you missed
one do you think that should be a half
billion dollar mistake
what about the people who implemented
the code reusing the feature does that
sound like a half billion dollar mistake
i was sure at some point there was a
meeting where somebody must have said
you know uh i think the transaction
limit on powerpeg might not be working
and somebody else said oh don't worry we
haven't used that code in in
10 years and it's going to be removed
soon anyway you know
these conversations they are worryingly
familiar
to anybody who's worked on on big i.t
systems because a lot of the
institutional knowledge just kind of
gets lost
stuff gets shut down but it never really
gets deleted and just occasionally
something that wasn't supposed to wake
up wakes up you know
now the night capital incident although
it was
uh you know a catastrophic thing for the
company the share price and potentially
the entire stability of the stock
exchange
it is still possible to trace through
every single step you know all that that
system
smarz was doing was it was doing what
human traders might have done
which is look at the market decide what
might be a good idea
and put in a bid and try and buy it it
was just doing it
fast really fast like hundreds of
millions of times per second
but with enough time and resources it
was possible to unpick the whole thing
roll it all back and figure out okay so
this happened
and then this happened and then this
happened and then this happened
we are now getting into an age where it
is no longer possible to do that
as we start exploring things to do with
you know machine learning convolutional
neural networks
we can build systems that they behave in
a certain way and we're like oh
okay well that's what they do i guess
there's an interesting example of this
from uh amazon recruitment now you know
there's recruitment is a huge challenge
anyone who's ever been looking for a job
or been hiring engineers for your team
recruitment takes up a lot of time and
energy for everybody working in software
um and you know that's one of the two
fundamental truths is recruitment is
hard job hunting is hard and another
fundamental truth is if you give
nerds a problem that takes a lot of time
and effort they will try and figure out
a way to automate it and that
is exactly what amazon did in 2014
they took all of the resumes the cvs of
everybody who had ever applied for a job
with amazon
and they said we want you to scan all of
these and we want you to look
for the patterns we want to find out a
way of looking at a cv you know feed
that through the algorithm and say do we
hire this person
yes or no and you know they had good
rigorous data on this they had records
of everybody who had applied
how far they got through the interview
process whether they subsequently got a
job
so they put a team on this and they ran
through all these cvs ran a bunch of
different models
and you know it worked they discovered a
very very
strong set of patterns what they
discovered
was that amazon's hiring policy was
systemically biased
they discovered that if your cv had the
name of
a college that only admitted women you
probably didn't get a job with amazon
they discovered that certain kinds of uh
sporting and you know recreational
activities outside university
that are generally popular with women if
those appeared on cvs those people
probably didn't get a job they found
other outliers but then when they
flipped it around they said well who did
we hire
there was no pattern at all what they
had discovered
is that the uh it wasn't a policy you
know this wasn't official the emergent
behavior
of the hiring procedures that were in
place at amazon
were effectively you know get rid of the
the
take out the women take out people who
don't look like us and then we'll just
randomly hire some selection of the
people that we have left
now they say they never ever used this
thing in production it was a research
project
it uh led to some you know fairly
difficult conversations
around how the whole hiring process at
amazon was working
the algorithms were working you know
they found the patterns it's just that
the patterns they found
were not patterns that anybody expected
or wanted
to see in there and you know this is an
interesting example of applying machine
learning
and unearthing some systemic bias in the
models that they were thinking hey we
can train a machine
to do what we do and the machine does it
and they go oh the machine is doing
horrible things
are we doing horrible things now this
happens
all the time here i want to show
something with share something with you
i first ran this
a couple of months ago and it was like
oh wow that's interesting
i'm sure that's going to be fixed soon
and yesterday i went in and i replicated
the experiment
posting images to twitter now twitter
when you upload photographs to twitter
it does some
machine learning analysis and it finds
the faces in the photographs
and it applies a crop to try and
highlight the bit of the picture that it
thinks you want to see first
now it does this it's only twitter's
official web and ios client it doesn't
happen on third-party things like
tweetdeck
because the metadata is only in
twitter's own system it's not in any of
their third-party apis
um so what i did last night i went on
twitter and i was like all right let's
post this picture
of nelson mandela and vladimir putin and
then i'll post the same picture
but the other way up with the pictures
in a different combination let's see who
twitter decides to highlight
and twitter goes yeah here's a the
relevant part of that picture even
though
the composition is is opposed so i tried
a couple more i'm like all right let's
try a
kanye western and jacinda ardern and it
got jacinda in both cases
beyonce and jay-z what do you think this
one's going to come up with this one got
beyonce in both of them
um i tried three copies of barack obama
and homer simpson
and twitter went homer both cases um and
finally
just because you know this was not a
rigorous experiment by any means i was
curious i was looking for
material to use in this talk and for a
bit of insight and i had to start
thinking about this problem
um i fired up photoshop and i made a
harrison ford wearing a denzel
washington t-shirt and denzel washington
wearing a harrison ford t-shirt
and this one it went no actually denzel
washington is the is the most
interesting face
whether he's on a t-shirt or not so
there is
some bias going on in this algorithm
somewhere the question is you know how
did it get there
now twitter said oh we're going to fix
this and that was months ago and they
haven't fixed it so uh
go and talk to twitter if you if you
think that they need to fix this thing
um what i'm interested in is i don't
think anyone sat down and said they're
going to do this on purpose
i believe that what we are seeing here
is
a kind of systemic problem that emerges
from
a failure to acknowledge the bias in the
underlying data sets and the composition
of the people who are working on these
things
it's about 8 billion people on this
planet now you know things like
ethnicity and gender they are not
absolutes they are a spectrum but if
you've got all the human beings on the
planet and you said look
anyone who identifies as white guys you
you come and stand over here everyone
will stay over there
you'd get about that many you know maybe
around
10 percent so if that's your sample set
and you as an engineer have an algorithm
that you're like it's 98
accurate because you've tested it on a
biased data set and then you've maybe
tested it on your co-workers
who also exhibit some of the same bias
your algorithm is actually more like
nine percent accurate when you apply it
to real people
and you know that's that's not good
enough in all kinds of ways
um from an engineering perspective the
lack of precision is horrible from a
moral and ethical perspective it's
excluding
you know huge swathes of people who are
like well i guess that algorithm just
doesn't care about people like me right
um so what are we gonna do about it well
first thing we have to do is
we need better data you know a lot of
the problem with facial recognition
stuff is that the public data sets
consist of famous people and the famous
people
tend to be the kind of people who get
famous in our society and a lot of them
tend to be white guys
um politicians leaders heads of state
movie stars sports people
all these kind of people there is an
overwhelming bias towards people who are
caucasian and present as male
and so you get this huge corpus of ten
thousand photographs that you found on
the internet to train your machine
learning model
there's bias there you know you haven't
done anything malicious
you just haven't realized that there is
this problem
and so you build it and then you try it
out on all the other people in your
engineering team
and you probably have a similar problem
you maybe don't pick up that the bias
exists
because again there is a problem with
the makeup of those teams not being
representative
of the planet as a whole so we need to
look out for this we need to start being
aware of the bias and the data sets
we're using to train these things we
need to start being aware of the
bias in the the teams that we're trying
it out with you know try and find a
bunch of people who are
nothing like the folks who sit next to
you in your office or who join your
slack every morning
be like can we work with you on trying
to get this thing right
um and we're going to change the world
and that sounds audacious
you know but think about the number of
things that we have changed already
by identifying the right problem finding
the people who care about it
and getting them to try and solve it we
are right now having a conference
even though nobody is allowed to travel
we have invented
writing and language and electronics and
radio and transistors internet email
wi-fi mobile app streaming video the
amount of technology involved in doing
what we are doing right now is
absolutely
astonishing and you know it can seem
like the world is a little bit of a
bleak place but if you look at some
key metrics um you know look at things
like a life expectancy
access to health care access to
information um hans rusling
the guy used to work with statistics at
the united nations he had this wonderful
one
number of playable guitars per person in
the world
has been increasing steadily since the
1950s
so on all kinds of metrics the world is
a better place than it's ever been and
it is still getting better and if you
need information you need to know how to
repair a tractor or fix a broken bone or
identify a parasite that's destroying
your crops you know that stuff is there
and it's online and it's free and it's
in hundreds of languages
and it's accessible to everybody you
know not just the the people who can get
library cards even kids can get online
and look this stuff up you know
um i grew up in zimbabwe i lived there
until i was about 10 years old
and if i wanted to know something i
could ask my parents i could ask my
teachers
or i could go to the library which was
okay that was not
the hugest library in the world it was
the borrowdale school library in harare
um but for really important questions
you know my questions as a kid were like
how fast can a bmx go
could a bmx go to space who'd win in a
fight between
optimus prime and darth vader i have no
idea because now you can google this
stuff
and you can go on and it's like i'm not
even actually going there
um but if you have these kinds of
questions it's easy and if you have
important questions questions about
health about
you know identity about gender and
there's nobody you can talk to people
all over the world they can go online
and they can type it into google and
they can get answers back saying it's
okay yeah it's normal
no you're just you're different to all
the other people who live in your little
town that's cool you know
um come out into the world and you'll
find people who like you and it's
absolutely fine don't worry about it and
i think that's worth it i think that's
valuable you know and if it takes us a
couple of decades to deal with fake news
and russian troll farms and
figure out a balance for the whole thing
i think it's worth it absolutely
because you know think about how much
we've accomplished we've wired the
planet we've got
blanketed the sky with satellites we've
uh trapped lightning in rocks until they
learn how to think
and along the way we've learned things
about the universe we've learned things
about ourselves now we've talked over
the last hour about a whole bunch of
different
models of computation we've talked about
number crunching
arithmetic high frequency algorithmic
trading spell checkers
machine learning information networks
and somewhere you know in the background
there's always this question
what kind of computers are we you know
what sort of computational model does
the human brain use
and will we ever be able to create an
artificial one
and there is a classic quote from edgar
dextre said the question
of whether a computer can think is no
more interesting than the question
of whether a submarine can swim now
there's a lot to unpack there and part
of the problem is we use the word
think to you know what is thinking our
thinking is what brains do
what our brains do oh they think you
know think about it think about
thinking the word think in english you
know what is a 127 plus 255 oh i think
it's around
200 and 370 something how do i get to
the library oh i think it's it's
up there across the street i think i
want a sandwich i think i love you i
think jimi hendrix is massively
overrated
um you know those are not the same
process
those are not the same kind of
computational model we are just
using think as an umbrella term for
stuff brains do and then being like why
can't computers think it's like well you
haven't phrased the question properly
you know
i want to look at one specific kind of
cognitive process
to close this at today i want to look at
uh you know playing a game of chess
now it turns out the oldest chess
programs are actually older than
computers
alan turing wrote one of the first chess
programs on pen and paper
and about 20 years later somebody
finally built a computer capable of
running it
um but for a long time people were
better than computers
at chess then in the 1990s it kind of
got neck and neck and then gary kasparov
the world champion grandmaster was
defeated
by an ibm computer called deep blue in
1997.
by the mid-2000s it was game over you
know the computers were consistently
winning every time
but after he was defeated by deep blue
gary kasparov created a new kind of
chess he called it advanced chair some
people call it centaur chess
cyborg chess hybrid chess um and the
idea of uh centaur chess
is that each team is each player is a
human and a computer
playing against another human and a
computer how good can they get if the
humans and the computers are working
together on the same side
and in the early days of cyborg chess
what they discovered was that a
reason like a home computer with a
reasonably good club chess player
could beat a human grandmaster because
there was something
about those two complementary analytical
styles
human creativity and mechanical
computation
that just made them a stronger chess
player and one of kasparov's
observations about this was the
the differentiating factor here the
thing that kind of controlled who won or
lost
wasn't the player or the computer it was
the quality
of the interface that existed between
them
you know how quickly could the person
have an idea
get it into the machine and understand
the response that said no no don't do
that if you do that it's a definite
background mate in 16 moves or something
you know the quality of that interface
the synergy that exists between the
person
and the machine and so that now brings
us onto the home stretch
because i took this idea about applying
you know how can we can we create
collaborations between human beings and
computers in a domain that i'm
interested in
which is is music now at ndc oslo
in june 2019 uh this guy michael lusak
he presented a talk about using a
machine learning model to write heavy
metal riffs
i'll show you a tiny little excerpt from
that talk here
so uh yeah so uh
i'm gonna play this
so it's not maybe a great piece of music
but it has some nice parts and it's uh
you know if you play it with enough
overdrive could be actually qualified of
metal
if you play it with enough overdrive it
could actually be qualified as metal
challenge accepted now we have some
music
i uh i emailed mikha and i said hey can
i have a copy of your
your tensorflow models and stuff and he
sent those over
um and you know i took that music that
his model created he fed it
all of the guitar music to all of
metallica's albums and then said write
me a new metallica song
that's what it came out with you got
music
i wanted lyrics now the state of the art
for getting machines to write text at
the moment
is a thing called gpt3 and gpt3 is a
machine learning algorithm
that uh generates english based on a
brief
last year the guardian newspaper
published an article
written by gpt3 they just gave it a
brief
they said you know this is the thing
you're gonna send an email to this
neural network
that is the kind of email you'd send to
one of your your your writers your
freelance journalists
and you're gonna publish what it sends
back and it wrote
i am not a human i am a robot a thinking
robot i use only 0.12
of my cognitive capacity i am a micro
robot in that respect i know my brain is
not a feeling brain but it is capable
of making rational logical decisions i
taught myself
everything i know just by reading the
internet and now i can write this column
my brain is boiling with ideas a machine
created this
now the article that the guardian ran
what they actually did was they took
eight different versions
and they picked the best bits and
someone said isn't that cheating and
they said no that's exactly what we do
with human journalists
is we'll we'll move bits around and edit
and structure and things
now i've been trying to get access to
gpt3 for about six months
and i still haven't probably because i
told them i wanted it to make metallica
lyrics
so for the lyrics of today's exercise we
are going to use a slightly more
uh pedestrian uh computational model
we're going to use something called a
markov chain
now markov chaining is just about taking
a whole bunch of text
and using statistical probability models
to go if i have this word
what word might come next i'd have a
very very quick work example for you if
we
took a markov chain and we trained it on
hotel california by eagles
and then we said right write me a line
of lyrics starting with she
now in hotel california she does various
things she stood in the doorway
she lit up a candle she showed me the
way she got the mercedes benz
and so it's just going to pick one of
those at random because the model knows
that those words can follow she let's go
with she showed
what did she show me well in the
original song she showed me the way
is the only thing she did so that's
always got to be me
what comes after me me the way bring me
my wine
neither me why 50 50. we'll go with that
one and what are the my things
in hotel california my hair my sight
grew dim bring me my wine we'll pick one
of those at random boom
she showed me my hair there we go that's
a line of eagles lyrics
now it's not terribly meaningful but
it's kind of you know it's grammatically
consistent and it captures something of
the flavor of the original piece right
and there is a website called lyrics.rip
that is markov chained all the lyrics to
all the bands ever and you can just go
on there
and you can type in uh if you go on
youtube there's a guy out there who's
performed all these kinds of songs and
he writes his own music
to go with the markov chained lyric
things um
and i thought let's go on the lyrics.rib
let's get metallica and get
that to generate some markov chained
metallica lyrics and i did
and i plugged them in and then i curated
what i found
i took mikhail's computer generated
music and i took the lyrics that rips
computer generated lyrics
and i went through them i was like right
that goes there that goes there that we
can't use
and created this
[Music]
rejection
what are the times
[Music]
here i go
so who wrote that song did metallica
write it
did mikhail write it did tensorflow
write it did i write it
i don't know i don't think anybody knows
but it still exists
as a result of this wonderful
synergistic
collaboration between machines and
computers and
i am gonna wrap it up there thank you
very much everybody for watching
thank you to the folks out on uh youtube
there for tuning in this morning if you
want to see the rest of the conference
get a ticket ndchyphenlondon.com you can
still grab yourself a ticket and come
join the rest of it
thank you very much to all the folks out
there watching on
webex we are out of time if you have
questions i will be on slack
conference slack for the next three days
come and find me in there
i hope you all enjoyed that i hope you
enjoy the rest of the conference you got
three days of amazing talks
presentations content ideas case studies
it's gonna be absolutely fantastic join
me at eight o'clock tonight for the nbc
virtual pub quiz uh join me tomorrow
evening we're gonna be doing a live
stream party with a
whole bunch of music and comedy and all
of those kinds of things
and uh don't forget to check out all of
our sponsors over on the the virtual ndc
expo
there's links to that in the conference
like for those of you who are watching
uh youtube folks it's been a pleasure
take it easy have a wonderful day
[Music]
so
you